I wondered about that too because you
know you hear about them actually you
hear middle-aged women now middle-aged
women oh they're like they are at their
sexual prime I think personally though I
didn't find any anybody would
specifically studied you know women
longitudinally like tracking them for
because you'd need to follow a group of
women over time and sort of you know see
how they've changed from their 20s to
40s but I I think what's going on a lot
of it time is that you know by the time
you get to your mid 30s or 40s as a
woman you know what you like and you
know how to make it happen or ask for it
or talk about it the other thing going
on is that you're you know what you've
got your birth control situation under
control you're not anxious about am I
going to get pregnant so you're just a
lot more confident and used to your body
and how it works and and you feel more
comfortable talking about sex you've
known your partner longer maybe there's
all kinds of things i think that
contribute to a woman feeling more
comfortable with sex more comfortable
making it happen the way it works for
her and being relaxed about it as
opposed to somebody who's sort of just
stepping out into the world of sex I
don't know hormonal ey that would be the
effect that would be the case I think
you know your hormones you tend to have
a decline in middle age and in in libido
and hormonal so I don't know why that
would I don't know why physically a
woman in middle age would be have a
better sex life than in her 20s
you